alors c'est gabriel béatrice et la merci
comment ça va
à moi maintenant et doué en gym avant
tu vois qu'on va en faire une danseuse
ouais
mentalité mais des bons mois je vais
sortir moi ben oui je vais sortir
ouais 10 dont je suis en train de
regarder toucher jalons là ils ont fait
un truc très rigolo qui s'appelle voirie
c'est une parodie de voici c'est très
drôle bien truquée à michael après les
beatles michael jackson pourrait à son
tour se reformer il ya posé le chien en
gastronomie c'est assez drôle bon ben
j'y vais je sors je sais pas je vois
ouais mais je t'appelle demain matin les
enfants vont bien ouais non mais je
t'embrasse à demain chablais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui fondent parviennent que cargo
[Musique]
m
besson
week-end
où est cameron
[Musique]
nick et moi
week-end mois
la paix
m
tha
ah ah
[Musique]
m
sofia
ouah
[Musique]
m
senio
oui quelle beauté
ok
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
google a
l'armée belge
au boulot comment ça va alors ben ça va
très bien ça fait combien de films
depuis concédé j'en ai fait trois de
plus res avance je porterai combien par
mois
j'ai fait un film tous les deux mois
ouais c'est cool comme jour de tournage
trois quatre jours ah bon en général car
maintenant alors été demandé
un balisage et gagner quand même lui ôte
donc non les starlettes c'est génial
pour moi je mets dans les facs en europe
les chiens dont on a gagné le vote non
pas des tubes avant enfin c'est quand
même très important pour moi c'est sa
couronne
ça fait que nous - q dans le x est en
fait avoir un tas d'or pour moi c'est
ici
moi je te vois là non c'est vrai ce que
tu dis mais bon il ya quand même
plusieurs actrices qui sont dans les xe
depuis trois ans quatre ans qui le
méritaient aussi mais bon c'est moi qui
vais je suis contente a fait un truc que
je me suis toujours demandé sais comment
j'ai pas quand tu baises avec des mecs
tu connais pas comme ça comment tu te
raconte des histoires dans la tête
un petit peu banon je pense qu'il faut
être excité un petit peu sur la scène
sinon
c'était pas excité tu as dû mater les
irritations dans les problèmes plus tard
est tous très bien excité tout fait un
petit fantasme dans la tête et tu
rigoles avec les médias ça se passe
super bien quoique tu travailles tu
t'imagines par exemple la tête
ouais ben déjà je commande un peu quand
même
sinon ben je m'invente une histoire
genre quoi le mec je fantasme soit sur
le mec ou alors vraiment je pense à
quelqu'un d'autre que avec qui j'ai fait
l'amour la veille ou l'avant-veille
voilà quoi c'était arrive et excité sur
commande comme ça c'est difficile quand
même mais bon quand c'est là pour le
travail il faut pas moi ce qui réduit
comme ça quoi quand et pas excepté sinon
ça se passe pas bien quoi pas très bien
long enfin moi les autres c'est pas
commun pour s'exciter s'est passé pour
une femme commence à te caresser du
regard des hommes et ça y est c'est
facile mais pourquoi tu prends pas des
crèmes ou déposer comme ça ça arrive ça
arrive
ouais si vraiment il ya un problème est
que ça dure trop longtemps la scène et
qu'on a on peut pas faire autrement
c'est un peu pénible pour moi on est un
peu de vaseline et c'est rare des
projets à part ça et bien figure toi oui
ça tombe bien il ya une solution
ouais si m'a proposé les premiers rôles
dans un single ils font du porte à faux
pas de porno attends je suis la première
à non ils m'ont proposé un premier rôle
et je vais voir cela sortir en septembre
normalement je commence début juillet le
tournage on va voir ses biens et non pas
vrai c'est que c'est dans ces rôles de
bain c'est le rôle d'une jeune femme qui
vient dans la province
ouais ok un peu réservé un petit but
quoi
et ouais t'es pas trop branché sur les
mecs tu vois en fait ils n'ont pas du
tout justement un bond très réservé et
timide
voilà très très catholique vient d'une
famille très catholique est en fait elle
devient elle est nommée prof de français
dans un lycée à paris
donc c'est un peu ça le résumé de
l'histoire comme et on va voir ça comme
toulalan patelin cadets le d'or ils sont
là un rôle d'une fille catholique qui
baissent bas et voilà ton énervé quand
on voit comme ça bah écoute
ouais pourquoi pas c'est incroyable et
bah tu sais ça arrive moi j'étais très
heureuse de faire ce film je voulais me
brancher un peu dans le site cédé c'est
le premier rôle à je suis je suis très
flatté métier que chehab est façon les
filles ne vois pas de pilote de vécu et
moi j'ai l'habitude un temps depuis 12
ans porte un pilote du premier
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
chasser toute l'année
m
tu fais toi
non
[Musique]
dans ce cas là
gérard
[Musique]
la vie est courte
mais
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
comment ça va voix soit à bien faire
jouer quoi j'étais en train de me re
jouer le bas 0 les quelques mots de t&d
fallait prendre quelques mois de quelque
chose de tennessee
ouais
[Musique]
y a un truc est pas comme dans
l'original
c'est quoi si ça fait ça c'est
l'original que tu connais à peu près
mais c'est vrai que cette chanson est là
et elle a toute une histoire parce que
avec michèle jeu là mais je l'avais
proposé au départ une chanson qui est
beaucoup plus longue beaucoup plus
compliquée que celle là on tapait dans
le gras on a on a enlevé des accords
n'enlevait de la mélodie est finalement
arrivé quelque chose de plus simple et
original c'était vraiment ça va
finalement carrément rien à voir presque
une autre chanson tu vois ça fait
[Musique]
et
c'est pas mal ça c'est moi ne tue pas
c'est moins tube automatiquement donc on
a quand même séduit karine joizil avait
choisi la première version à la fois que
tu vas en premier la wii au fond on a on
a travaillé un peu sur les mélodies en
se disant on va faire quelque chose un
petit peu moins faible 1
et puis on était arrivés sur cette suite
de notes qui filent tubes qu'on connaît
quoi là tu l'avais connu comment michel
berger c'est une longue histoire
on s'est connus en en 1975 mais tgt
pénis dans un bar ouais et je faisais je
vais pas mal de choses et des cours je
prenais des cours d'orchestration la
scala quant aux roms il fallait bien
bien ma vie donc du coup perd son
maillot
si si tout à fait sur la table du et
dûment du vrai alors tu disais tu étais
à la schola cantorum est alors donc je
jouais dans les bars le soir pour
évidemment gagner ma vie c'est un soir
débarque michel berger avec ses petits
camarades de jeu
ouais et puis
chemin faisant je commence à jouer des
calices de pièces de bach oui tout à
fait sans plus et puis je me faisant la
nuit avance ans michel se met au piano
avec moi puis on recommence à deviser de
de musique
et puis ça se passe très très bien
d'ailleurs on avait à peu près le même
cursus musical un haut niveau d et la
formation de 500 du mans et ça tombait
très bien ça veut dire qu'on parlait et
puis comme finalement je lui ai fait
écouter quelque chose quelque peu donc
quelques compositions que je faisais sur
le moment il m'a donné son adresse
et du coup le lendemain je les ai
rappelés on l'appréhendé vous et on
s'est revus comme ça voilà et tutu à
l'époque tu jouer quelqu'un quel type de
match où par exemple on jouait pas
encore de type de morceaux jetez moi
j'essayais de m'immiscer dans le domaine
de la composition mais c'était pas très
facile parce qu'il faut il faut avoir
pas mal de relationnel de relations moi
j'étais issu du milieu classique c'était
pas du tout show biz très très peu et en
fait michel berger je le connaissais
déjà par véronique sanson mais c'était
un personnage qui était pour moi
relativement critique déjà tu verras
comment jacques comment il a été fait
contre un qui voulait à la revoilà le
dit chante les champs poil alors du coup
voilà du coup je lui ai joué quelques
mélodies comme par exemple
la groupie du pianiste des choses comme
ça qui sont sortis beaucoup beaucoup
plus tard boxe à peu près 15 ans après
des des thèmes comme ça des choses que
j'avais ce sont des choses que j'ai
composées alors en fait café michel
c'est comme il n'avait pas le temps et
ils n'avaient pas non plus quelquefois
nous les artistes ont quelquefois des d
inspiration un peu défaillante et que
finalement les thèmes lui plaisait bien
et la société il a créé une société
d'auteurs dont le nom générique et
michel berger et en fait on partager les
droits
en fait je lui faisais les mélodies lui
faisait quelques modifications
éventuellement sur la ferme en fait je
m'ai fait quasiment tous les tubes que
tu connais et puis en définitive voilà
quoi mais toi non mais jamais apparu je
suis moi si ça ne tenait pas envie de la
reconnaissance de non ça ne
m'intéressait pas ton n'est pas fair et
le travail en background tu vas des
maires de mise en place des choses
éventuellement de surveillants de
l'orchestration de choses comme ça
franchement voilà mais l'aide du poteau
et quand maintenant je sais pas
peut-être oui tu as ça a pas mal marché
quoi pour les personnes là dessus cette
histoire c'est incroyable c'est fou non
il n'y avait même pas de secret si tu
veux ouais vous cachez pas vos noms
sachets pas vraiment ce qu'il ya c'est
que bon si tu dis aujourd'hui c'est
parce que tu mènes minutes parce que
finalement jamais pensé en fait le
problème après c'est que quand il
aimante à carrière s'est arrêtée vous
avez raison oui c'est arrêter oui bien
entendu parce que c'est vrai que ma
collaboration était relativement
unilatérale était alité basé sur mon ma
relation avec michèle dain et puis pour
le reste c'est vrai que j'avais personne
a coutume ça m'intéressait pas vraiment
fait beaucoup de travail et enfin non
maintenant c'est
c'est un peu différent à temps je suis
en train de faire les morceaux de michel
rideau à voir la highway
voilà je suis en train de préparer un
album ouais et cette fois-ci bon c'est
moi qui s'ils anticipent cette fois à
ses six de temps non voilà c'est dingue
tu veux pas me jouer une des chansons
que oui parce que j'ai en effet pour
starmania j'en ai fait pas mal partout
[Musique]
où
oh
à eschede chansons qu'il a pas eu le
temps d'écouter que tu l'avais écrite et
qu'il appelle temps d'écouté ah bah oui
je vais en avait fait une base juste
avant son accident quoi et qui est une
chanson un peu triste d'ailleurs c'est
assez curieux parce que c'était une
sorte de préméditation enfin présage pas
plus beaux passages pardon sur ce qui
allait arriver
et puis on rend définitive il n'a jamais
entendu il a jamais entendu et c'est
dommage parce que je pense que c'était
une belle chanson c'est qu'ils auraient
pu faire une belle carrière j'étais
saoul bien oui bien sûr par contre je
suis pas chanteur c'est aussi une des
choses et qu'elle n'ait jamais voulu
mettre à l'avant de la fiche parce que
si je me met à chanter c'est un drame
quoi alors ça faisait à peu près ça je
crois
[Musique]
demain
mais
tous
non
[Musique]
noble
là
tous
bon
[Musique]
tiens
mais c'est pour
leur blog
ansa
si toi
tiens pourquoi pour savoir ce que je
vais faire à la rentrée à une question
tu étais quoi comme si capricorne
c'est un signe merveilleux qui a
émerveillé c'est merveilleux alors que
thierry déjà l'année prochaine tu lui a
coûté déjà cette année
cette semaine durant cette semaine tu ne
fait pas ton anniversaire ça c'est sûr
tu es tranquille de ce côté là alors
pour c'est pour l'année prochaine et
coûte que je dirais alors ce qu'on peut
lire en santé écoute paris ne s'est pas
fait en un jour tu vois et je crois
qu'il ya loin de la coupe aux lèvres
ouais l'amour tu t'intéresses l'amour à
bon chat bon rat comme disait paulo
coelho tu connais bon chat bon rat la
scène coule sous les ponts
écoute un tiens vaut mieux que deux tu
l'auras verts de la ville un garde l'a
bien là son tour lebron et les bonnes
tailles squatteuse tête a une aura
denton bonora ménages telle monture mais
si tu veux ce qu'on peut faire c'est
quelque chose que je fais assez rarement
je fais pour des pour des gens comme toi
fin tu vois des gens un peu qui peuvent
m'aider et entre eux avec qui on peut
s'entraider si tu veux ce que je peux
faire c'est une lecture de la pasta
alors ça ça vient de mon grand-père en
fait qui est mon arrière-grand-père même
fait faisait ça déjà coûte le le mieux
c'est qu'on fasse sens ans mais j'ai
besoin de ta collaboration ce que tu es
prêt à aller un peu loin parce que tu es
prêt ce qu'on aille un peu à un sort
lundi elle a tiré porte à la pac c'est
ça
la rive immédiat mais c'est quoi alors
tu lis l'avenir dans les pattes
thierry tu as vraiment ainsi vraiment un
signe éclatant et une aura
extraordinaire je jouais à quelque chose
là vraiment tu de ta tête
d'extraordinaire que je vois très très
rarement en fait c'est moi alors je vais
te faire oui la lecture de la pasta pour
répondre à ta question
tu vois je pourrais tellini mes diplômes
je préfère je préfère te montrer ce que
ce que j'arrive à voir donc
il paraît qu'on peut lire dans tout en
fait am exactement par exemple celle et
on peut dire aussi bien dans plein de
trucs moi je lis dans les cheveux je lis
dans la plante des pieds qui est souvent
négligée en fait par les peuples dans la
profession j'ai atteint mon avis et
c'est comme les maria des lignes soit
délicieux mets toute affaire il ya des
lignes des méandres il ya les sinuosités
la vie tient en fait c'est exact savons
qu'au gré oui la plante des pieds tu as
fait très tôt qu'elle sait jamais
comment 10 est prête tiens je vais
vraiment avoir besoin de toi est ce que
tu peux mettre des mains merci il faut
qu'il faut qu'elles se touchent
ok ou là ok ok écoutons s'ouvriront va
ouvrir thierry attention on va ouvrir
voilà ok tu t'inquiètes pas tu ne va
rien sentir ta rien sans toi tu vas
prendre une poignée s'il te plait je
vais prendre une poignée avec tes mains
ça va ça va sans rien ça brûle paul
souffle souffle thierry souffle thierry
klein dieng radiait là les a fait cuire
tuchan pensons à toi tu sais quand tu
attendais on peut dire que c'est un peu
préparé et qu'on attendait donc on a
face à elle en a fait son chemin chez
les fabricants à chaque fois tu fais pas
il faut que tu apprécies tu le jettes
dirait que tu as le jette aux oubliettes
l'habitude les jette toi là d'accord il
me faut encore un peu plus un tout petit
peu plus s'il te plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
rien
puis plus rien
[Musique]
et
il
le
[Musique]
là
tu as nationaux je suis voilà votre
carte gim collectif gênantes au nic la
boisson des jambes toniques
non mais c'est vraiment bien qu'est ce
que tu fais et bah écoute qu'est ce que
je fais je continue à écrire je vais
parler des
cg un roman je vais sortir tous les
villes mythiques du monde et qui
s'appelle mistral alors 1 mais surtout
surtout je comprends je plais 5e j'étais
un peu seule chose une fois un peu ce
père est pas passé un peu à larrau
mortifère actuel de montrer quand même
des gens qui font des choses il ya des
choses qui bougent pour la cinquième
fois un probablement est autrement je
continue à écrire dacquois com
aucun train là je faire un bouquin
qui s'appellera parole de france qui a
un peu tout ce que tu sais pendant
quatre ans j'ai tourné pour les missions
etc
mais c'est pas sûr l'émission c'est bon
la france comme système vietnam est en
guerre est allé sur les lignes de front
ouais aussi bien le prendre la pause ion
qu'est-ce qui se casse la gueule qu'est
ce qu'il va faire chômage racisme
sécurité peur et c'est ce qui va aussi
parce qu'il est attirant parle quelque
chose qui ne font pas état de choses qui
vont très très bien et qu'ils mangent et
notre général qui se bougent le cul et
qui n'attendent pas qui pleure pas des
matériaux soir pour voir ce qu'il peut
se passer
donc voilà montrer la merde organisée
devant le français c'est ça ouais pas
mal
états unis et puis alors j'ai un scoop
avant parce que c'est puskas que je vais
tenir
c'est quelque chose dont
je suis très fier qu'on peut annoncer
que personne ne sait en tout cas que
personnellement je suis un mois et demi
il ya un mois et demi du toit est à
genève est
j'ai un ami qui avocat qui connaît à
banquiers berg et en suisse tu vois
c'est comme stripteaseuse à pigalle
autant et le type peur et me dit est ce
que vous connaissez j'aime inscrit je
sais que personne ne publier je sais que
je ne peux pas la vérité ne laisseront
pas je sais quoi
l'audi des entretiens entre jean paul
sartre et sur jenny cie sodeci
ce pareil mais monsieur se sont
rencontrés quatre jours ce que c'est
clair la socgen ici la quittez là aussi
c'est même le quitter l'urss à l'époque
donc en 74
ouais il a vécu quelques mois zurich way
et quand il était à zurich
j'allais suit avec jean paul sartre
demont voix ils ont discuté par cas jean
moi j'étais moi même si dental
l'écrivain l'écrivain de l'est qui a
tout foutu en l'air et ils sont vus
pendant quatre jours ils se sont parlés
par une quinzaine d'heures ouais et le
type avant son coffre fort et avec quoi
ça fait trois cents pages et moi ça fait
400 pages 400 pages je vois ça fait
quatre cents pages
bonsoir et bien d'ailleurs je me disais
bien un petit peu durable
et alors le mec le mec tu files le mec
tu viens le monde le manuscrit de la
faillite signer sa vie c'est le
manuscrit des dialogues et c'est
extraordinaire parce que ça veut dire 20
ans donc maintenant plus de 20 ans et ça
n'a pas perdu une minute c'est à dire
que soljenitsyne expliquant pourquoi
j'aime ça devait disparaître ça qui crée
abandonner tout anticommuniste d'un
chien je me sentirais pas de l'amicale
pas été très attaquées par les
communistes qui essaie de comprendre
mystique le côté mystique de l'autre et
qui n'arrive pas à passer ça et c'est à
dialogue extraordinaire d'intelligence
entre le plus grand nationaliste le
sur les théories c'est la liberté et le
tgv de tennyson la spiritualité et c'est
à la fois très très grands affrontements
s'étaient alors le problème si tu veux
c'est que ce binz king piste et que le
problème c'est que comme tu sais ce
génie des vérités pas rien chez
gallimard il ya un problème évidemment
de droit a dit ça qui se pose est le
problème c'est que billy ne savent pas
les deux éditeurs ou du lourd et ils le
savent et prétend de pasaban et ont
aligné dans toutes les zones
ouais on va tenter le coup non pas
d'édition peut être pas l'interdire les
paladins dans la sarthe qui discute avec
celui ci en plus personne personne
n'aurait imaginé que les rangs français
nous sommes soudés car elle est peu plus
grands conscience je t'ai pas dit que
c'était peut-être un faux quand on
écoute bien sûr je me suis dit ça cela
dit j'ai quand même lu tout ça et j'aime
beaucoup de soljenitsyne très
sincèrement ça le droit d'y aller c'est
tellement fort et puis je m'étais alors
là aussi ses impôts c'est aussi bien
d'abord et puis les photos
malade un jury de près de la villa où il
était et je te dis ce client c'est que
ça te train sa parfaite ce demi siècle
tout va de ces années là comme jamais
c'est la rencontre du demi-siècle
absolument certain seuil et intello
wallace et ses soeurs quant à leur insu
alors ça sort en septembre
ah ouais c'est moi la presse est prêt et
je vais te dire ça va faire c'est pour
moi ça va réviser nommément de
chaussures compensées de centaines chez
disney par son bois que ces gens là qui
étaient aux antipodes sont capables
d'élaborer leurs appels matin et s qui
produisent des choses ensemble est ce
que est ce que ils restent sur leur
position ils s'affrontent us que non un
moment ils arrivent à produire des
haches mettre d'accord sur des choses à
dire qu'ils mettent d'accord sur sarko
diamant de l'insuline gît au fond c'est
votre liberté qui s'exerçait comme ça
vous avez choisi votre islam se dessine
la mener à bien sa maison mais aussi il
ya des choses plus importantes que la
rationalité de la liberté voilà
et si tu veux là tu as quelque chose qui
est vraiment c'est c'est comme si
j'avais rencontré
moi je dirais même si c'est pas d'un
siècle et c'est vraiment moi j'ai voyagé
tu pourras la loire dans le site de
données d'un petit bonus j'aimerais nuit
vous et je vais te dire je t'en parle
mais j'ose pas enfin ça c'est très
embêtant soutenir les gens vont dire
mais c'est pas possible
j'attends une réaction de maillard
ailleurs
il
[Musique]
et qu au putsch en retard
il
m
bonsoir allez voir ça va là tu va
m'aider sur ce tableau
bah je prépare une exposition au musée
d'art moderne de new york moma ses
lauriers
maman et c'est une exposition sur le
corps c'est alors je vais te montrer bon
parce que pour le moment je fais des
essais je fais d'état décès mais il ya
des oeuvres qui sont bon goût que c'est
présenté tel quel tu vois c'est quoi
cette entrée que buddy reliques well as
alors c'est ça ça s'appelle body
reliquaire c'est à base de des
sécrétions de mon corps c'est tout ce
que mon corps à ces traités tu vois
alors bon bien sûr tu as le 120 d'abord
évidemment alors qu'à une plaque de sang
comme ça tu vois et mis dans des poches
de plexiglas en général c'est à ces
fraises tu vois alors on voit me sens à
certains endroits bougez coin ça ce sont
mes sécrétions vaginales tu vois c'est
bien tu récupères comment c'est très
simple je fais des prélèvements ou les
matins de préférence parce que c'est le
meilleur moment pour les sécrétions
vaginales
elles sont restées tu vois toute la nuit
alors bon après je peux les est prélevé
a besoin de gynécologues pour ça ça se
sont bas mais mes cheveux je me suis
coupé les cheveux je vois et puis je les
ai mis aussi comme ça j'en ai fait un
tel rythmique quoi mais au dessus c'est
quoi alors ça c'est de de l'uriné mais
bon c'est un peu sec par contre je dois
avoir de l'uriné fraîche quelque part et
je me demande si finalement je ne vais
pas présenté tu vois il faudrait quand
même que ce soit bon c'est ton dur est
passé mon urine évidemment tout ça c'est
à base de mon corps présent de la
thielle urines et puis tu as le rin
d'artistes pitch halte à la mère de
l'artiste
tu vois ça se présente comme sa mère de
l'artiste voit tiens toi ça a c'est à
moi ça tranquillement à moi tu vois j'ai
besoin de personne pour aller le
chercher
alors tu vois ça va aussi jusqu'à par
exemple mais peau morte alors l'ordre
bon bah ouais graca sur la baignoire par
exemple qu'il expose ben c'est difficile
j'ai pris simplement de l'eau sale ouais
super league
voilà j'ai pris l'eau du bain tu vois
alors ça se présente comme ça et puis
j'ai une oeuvre ou alors on voit bien le
sens aussi qu'elle a alors celle là elle
est prête à être exposés c'est une
grosse poche est bon dans trois jours je
peux sur sa non ça c'est du sang dans
trois jours je vais subir une
liposuccion et alors on va extraire le
le grade de mes cuisses et de mon ventre
enfin et puis je vais le mettre un
reliquaire je pense à une boîte comme ça
où ado 6 à 2 parce que la liposuccion
c'est un peu un peu orange quoi c'est un
liquide un peu non comment eh bien ça
doit être moi j'en ai jamais fait de
liposuccion mais je pense que ça doit
être comme du gras tu vois ça doit être
un peu mélangé bien sûr a du sens mais
ça doit être plus gras foie alors tu
vois là on voit bien l'oeuvre
je trouve ça beau toit
bah oui moi je trouve ça aussi les
américains qu'ils adorent non les
américains ils sont très très très
tristes or là bas tu vois des tas
d'artistes qui me qui me soutiennent
comme jointe par exemple marie de la
cicciolina ouais alors lui il est fou de
mon oeuvre
c'est buren aussi les médias style heavy
rain en france alors il ay mais il a
même obtenu pour moi de l'argent
jacques toubon pour me faire
subventionnés par l'état subventionné
par les tentes
exactement c'est l'état qui me peine tu
vois toutes mes recherches tout mon
matériel
parce que sans moi alors ça c'est
vraiment du sens tu vois on le voit
vraiment bien alors tu vois le soir du
vernissage
je serai habillé avec une robe en steak
au après faire une robe en steak
du cousu voilà c'est ça alors le seul
inconvénient c'est que c'est un peu
lourd
tu vois toute la soirée je vais ployer
sous le poids du steak et passer d'elle
elle va un peu plus et parce que bon la
robe on va pas la faire le jour même
quoi c'est en veulent à turin deux
semaines avant c'est toujours sur le
concept de l' enveloppe corporelle qui
n'est qu'un sac et sur lequel qui est un
terrain d'investigation pour l'artiste
[Musique]
du neuf à votre bonne chose
une ode à
là
esparros ses deux yeux
mais
oui comme très beau ce chien way we
s'appelle face et il n'a pas non encore
à s'appeler rex je pense dans deux ou
trois mois
ouais sa future ex merde qu'est ce qu'il
fait comme c'est quoi comme un comme
chien c'est d'abord ça me navre adore
labrador de trois mois tu pourras tu
pourra louer pour une soirée se plaint
ben ça c'est un chien ce tout ça va te
faire rigoler c'est un chien qui est qui
va être dressé
et on va s'en servir pour le d'offrir et
le louer à des couples qui aiment rien
faire les trucs avec les animaux c'est
vrai mais plutôt avec les chiens qui
avec des animaux fait arrêter ce loup
ouais ça seul ou bien c'est bon esprit
quand même si tu vois à première vue on
se dit c'est un peu spécial et en fait
c'est un business qui marche bien et
puis tiens comme ça tu vois c'est ça
leur fait du bien il aime bien ça et
puis en plus on peut rendre des gens
dingues et des sociétés qui loue des
suites société alors commence à peine
elle s'appelle hot dog a fait pas qu'on
a réussi à faire un petit peu tous les
styles ou des chiens pour des oueds dans
ses rangs graf
ça dépend en fait soyons des nations et
les mecs seul os x c'est des couples
c'est arrivé de faire des gangs bangs
avec avec sept huit chiens un seul nana
aux mineurs
tu leur apprend à coulaures pas que j'y
fais quand ils baisent a lancé un c'est
un peu long c'est tu veux c'est à dire
que en fait on passe de 3 - la sage on
les prend quand ils ont à peu près de
moyens trois mois on les prend les dres
moment de trois mois ont fait des gaffes
qui griffent pas on essaye de les
dresser pour que et puis ça vous voyez
pas ce que les gens aiment bien ce à un
moment donné quand ils font des trucs
avec nos chiens il a vu l'artiste et on
lui a appris aussi parce que quand ils
font l'amour avec le film s'il est bon
les animaux les chiens c'est bien connu
il faut des seaux d'eau et de trucs
comme ça dont conservant jeu pour qu'ils
puissent eux ces cartes juste à temps
pour bien se passer sur le corps à tous
les trucs quoi mais c'est un service
jeunesse des marges il ya quoi comme
chiendent à louer dans cette suite on a
quelques labrador on a pas mal de
dobermann ça c'est cette fontaine les
aime bien avoir le doberman avec le
cognac vraiment le petit narcier type du
chien et la partie des gens qui louent
sa écoute moi ça fait trois ans que je
fais ça maintenant et on a une clientèle
qui est exclusivement parisienne et plus
ça va plus on avec le peu de clients
on avait au début on les a tous gardé
c'est tous des fidèles c'est des gens
qui sont restés
des contacts des relations sans arrêt
tintin on a fait beaucoup de choses avec
eux ils nous ont mis en contact un
d'autres gens et nous sommes en contact
avec d'autres gens et ça nous a permis
d'avoir une espèce de filières et puis
quand on a fait du marketing là dessus
des mailings pas d'e mailing mais on
sait maqué avec des boîtes tu sais
qu'ils jouent les cassettes chier tous
exactement sa voix la tendance donc on
fait des échanges avec eux on leur fait
d'une petite comme et puis en échange il
nous fit de l'ordre bening pour l'heure
tous les gens quoi mais peut-être
commencer comment dans ce business
ah ça c'est complètement par hasard en
fait moi je sortais du sortait du lycée
et j'étais parti de faire du camping
avec mes parents c'était il ya quatre
ans c'était sur la côte est un moment
donné on rentrait un soir et puis on
était plusieurs potes et on l'aimait
bien regardé ce qui se passait dans les
tentes voit et on était rentrés dans une
tente on regarde et on voyait un couple
qui était en train de de toucher un
chien la dernière elle s'en occuper et
tous et qui ont débuté bizarre qu'on
avait pu en fait on a continué à
regarder ils sont aperçus qu'on était là
et du coup ils nous ont branché et on a
discuté avec eux et tout ils ont dit que
c'était pas sale enfin ils ont expliqué
leurs théories dessus ils nous ont
expliqué qu'ils avaient une grosse
filière de gens qui aimaient vraiment ça
qui avait si quelqu'un se donner la
peine de le faire il y aurait pas un
vrai business
tu veux prescrire décidé de le faire bah
ouais avec un pote comptable un mec qui
est dresseur qu'on a comme handicap a
touché aso entreprises en france c'est
clair et ça marche bien l'avouer plutôt
l'international non c'est vrai en europe
c'est pas interdit du moment que ont
fait pas mal au chien sociale interdit
si jamais tu goudé si jamais tu joues
des chiennes bah ouais c'est à dire que
t'as pas le droit en fait de te faire
des trucs à l'animal à l'intérieur de
son corps ou des trucs comme ça
le chien c'est lui qui fait
donnez les trèfles ou là dessus donc
inattaquables on a absolument aucun
problème c'est aussi bien pour les
utilisateurs que pour pour nous quoi
donc non ça le fait bien ça fait bien on
est assez content je veux dire c'est
c'est sûr que je m'en vante pas tous les
jours auprès des parents de mes petites
familles et on dit qu'on a un chenil
mais que pour des chiens tu vois en
kilos mais la location de chiens c'est
vraiment est juste il faut que ça va
être un bon [__] celui-là lui à mon
avis assez petit labrador comme ça
généralement ça donne toujours des bons
résultats sur les nanas qui aime bien
qu'ils sont un peu tendre tu vois ces
nanas qui ont vu en vrai c'est un peu
léger comme ça le visage à droite à
gauche et lui bah je pense que je vais
arriver à le vendre
paal vente parce que dieu m'en garde les
gars tous mes chiens mais lui je vais
louer entre entre 3500 et 4500 passé la
soirée à thème j'ai fait mes
oui oui oui pas comme les clients non
attends mais quand on a une sexualité
ouais ouais ça c'est mon truc c'est vrai
que j'en parle patron mais normal
ouais normal comme tout le monde mais si
tu veux je m'adapte aux besoins des
clients
moi j'ai besoin de faire du business à
un moment donné ça ça le fait bien
j'aime bien les animaux à la base des
chiens je les connais bien et puis voilà
quoi
on a un saint-bernard aussi ouais ouais
ça bernard parce qu'ils les nanas qui
ont le le qui aime bien avoir des petits
sur l humain de ces syndromes du yéti
mais enfin on en a plein amelia bras
d'or c'est vraiment les plus cools
essais les plus faciles dans les
batteries coulter c'est à lui et
emmanuel on y croyait
bon ben on s'y croirait un oui
évidemment c'est pas du tout la vérité
bon pas mal
or on y croit félicitant les croire je
voulais simplement dire que tout ça
c'était un tissu de mensonges ne l'est
jamais malheureusement rencontré michel
berger ni même croisé sur mon chemin ce
que je regrette bien parce que c'est un
une personne qui remet mon admiration
tu crois que jean lancray que tu es
devenue une actrice ab strict de à bec
et je vais le rôle d'une bâche espère
jean bonjour est ce que tu allais ouais
je crois que les gens ont pu le croire
moi moi je pense aussi way
et
rien rater de li na l'a redit tube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux